Deadpool everybody loves him and with
good reason as a character he's a
reverent and unpredictable
he tends to shake things up in both
comics and movies asking the real
questions that fans have always wondered
about wait out here okay it's a big
house it's funny that I only ever see
two of you it's almost like the studio
couldn't afford another x-man Deadpool
wasn't always the butt whomping
fast-talking immortal mercenary that he
is today here's a brief history of
Deadpool's weirdest moments in comics
movies and videogames stroke of genius
to be clear up front Deadpool is pretty
much an unoriginal character writer
Fabian Nicieza was trying to cobble
together a coherent script for Marvel's
New Moon's based on artist Rob Liefeld
plots and characters when he noticed
that Liefeld basically copied the DC
Comics character Deathstroke like
Deathstroke Liefeld's Deadpool was also
a super agile mercenary and the two are
visually similar enough to make the
weird copy unmistakable bringing the
arroba rows of unoriginal tea full
circle DC Aiza gave deadpool the real
name of wade wilson in reference to
Deathstroke's real name Slade Wilson
cable subscription Deadpool first
appeared in 1991 in New Mutants number
98 where he was written as a mercenary
who came out of nowhere to attack the
hero known as cable don't know who cable
is a co-creation of Liefeld and writer
Louise Simonson cable is the son of
Cyclops and a clone of Jean Grey and
he's from the future what's cable made
every x-men comic infinitely more
complicated by introducing time travel
and alternate timelines but despite the
fact that the twos don't actually have
much in common
Deadpool a cable have been linked in
comics ever since Merc with a mouth
eventually Deadpool outgrew his
traditional villainous roots and became
a fan favorite that's thanks in large
part to what is now known as his
signature stick breaking the fourth wall
and addressing readers directly the in
story explanation is that Deadpool is
just nuts so of course he thinks that
he's a fictional character but fans
can't help but love a hyper violent
antihero who has just as much to say
about the state of superheroes as they
do when it comes to time to licking
wounds there's no
like home I share that home with someone
you've met the old blind lady from the
laundromat oh god I miss cocaine her
fourth wall break inside a fourth-wall
break that's like 16 walls ultimate
Deadpool mainstream Marvel's Deadpool is
the guy that everyone knows and loves
the Marvel's handling of the character
across different universes and media has
been kind of terrible in an attempt to
return Deadpool to his villainous
origins the Ultimate Marvel line of
comics saw a Deadpool who was an insane
cyborg war veteran with no skin and
clear helmet to keep his brains from
falling out hell-bent on destroying all
mutants not only was ultimate Deadpool
hunting mutants for a TV show but he was
also a shapeshifter because it's
surprisingly easy to write stupid comics
fortunately for all the comic book fans
out there the real Deadpool eventually
stuck a sword right into the crappy one
man it felt good
agent X for a little while in the early
2000s Marvel convinced comic readers
that they've killed off Deadpool and
brought him back as a new character
called agent X Y because Deadpool sales
numbers were flagging and dropping an X
into a Marvel title has always been in a
cash machine it wasn't enough to save
Deadpool and it was also just enough to
frustrate dedicated Deadpool fans into
dropping the book entirely even writer
Gail Simone was frustrated with Marvel's
editors and abandoned the book after
less than a year leaving other writers
to reveal that agent X was in Deadpool
at all but some weird psychic mashup of
other characters
fortunately Deadpool's return to the
spotlight has been pretty successful
after that speechless it's really hard
to forget the Deadpool's first big
screen appearance was a tragedy in 2009
s x-men origins Wolverine Ryan Reynolds
plays a sexy ninja version of the
character capable of deflecting
machine-gun fire with a swords but wait
it gets worse in the course of the film
he dies and is reassembled into a
jambalaya of a guy with other mutant
powers and no mouth yes the Merc with a
mouth didn't have a mouth
needless to say fans weren't pleased
Deadpool the video game the Deadpool
from x-men origins Wolverine left such a
bad taste and viewers mouths that the
gamers flock to 2013
Deadpool video game which was far truer
to the characters form but um making
repeated references to the games budget
and script
Deadpool breaks the fourth wall and does
ridiculous stuff for it to feel like a
legitimate entry into the Deadpool canon
well isn't that handy unfortunately
critics gave the game a lukewarm
reception even still for lots of fans it
was one step closer to a true Deadpool
movie the one that everyone had been
waiting for
Reynolds redemption as unhappy as
Deadpool appearance and x-men origins
made fans no one was more disappointed
than Ryan Reynolds himself I remember
telling one of the studio execs I said
you guys are gonna they're gonna people
are gonna go nuts over this and he was
like I know right I was like they're not
that good no not no insane Deadpool
character you can't do this to w and
they just said well we're gonna it'll
work watch in the years that followed
Reynolds became something of a champion
for the long-delayed spin-off movie
starring the character in 2012 20th
Century Fox commissioned CGI test
footage from visual effects artist Tim
Miller the result was a two-minute scene
starring Reynolds who provided the voice
for an over-the-top crazy violent
Deadpool doing what he does best
cracking jokes and skulls in equal
measure
still Fox's executives sat on the
footage for two years until it's somehow
leaked onto the Internet in 2014
fans went wild the film was greenlit and
in 2016
Deadpool broke weekend box office
records for an r-rated movie earning 135
million dollars in just three days
eat that Deathstroke
[Applause]
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know about your
favorite Deadpool moment